I want to start today by talking
generally about political violence in
the United States what I mean by this is
acts of real world violence that are
politically motivated or politically
oriented and of course the context is
this horrifying attack by a right-wing
anti-vaccine
anti-semitic Q Anon nut on Nancy
Pelosi's husband Paul Pelosi which we
will get to but one of the things that
the right has been doing in response to
this horrible attack to this obviously
politically motivated attack is a lot of
both sidesing well we generically
condemn violence and violence is bad no
matter who does it violence in general
is unacceptable but let's not pretend
that it is the same on both sides first
of all they aren't actually telling the
truth that they see left and right-wing
violence in the same way their reaction
to the January January 6 Trump riots
excuse me is great evidence of that but
more importantly they are looking to say
well just violence is bad but
overwhelmingly the violence comes from
their side there's a very good study
from the new America Think Tank which
found that most political violence is
right wing and in fact they have number
of people killed in deadly attacks in
the post-9 11 ERA this is for deaths and
then we have other incidents of violence
where nobody dies number of people
killed by ideology and you will see that
there's 122 which are far right wing and
107 that are jihadist 17 are ideological
misogynist slash in cells which is
another right-wing reactionary ideology
then you've got your black separatist
Nationalist supremacists and one that is
far left wing
other than the one far left wing these
are all essentially right-wing
ideologies now you might say but David
the jihadists folks jihadists are right
wing tell me what left-wing views
jihadist Muslims have they have the
exact same views as the far-right
Christians except under the guise of
Islam rather than Christianity
so overwhelmingly right wing violence is
the cause of of a death in the United
States in politically violent acts
there's another study uh called a
comparison of political violence by
left-wing right wing and Islamic
islamist extremists in the United States
and the world and what this study finds
and we'll link to it and you can read
through it is that most political
violence both domestically in the United
States and globally is carried out by
right-wing ideology by right-wingers now
there is another layer
it isn't just the right wing that is
perpetrating most of the political
violence it's also that the left wing is
mostly the victim of that violence as
well you can have right Wingers
generically committing acts of violence
and the victims are A random assortment
of those based on political ideology but
no it is left Wingers that are
overwhelmingly the victims of this
right-wing violence as well and if you
think we can count on the right to help
reduce such violence forget it think
back to the start of the pandemic they
couldn't even pitch in and just wear
masks or get themselves vaccinated for
the greater good there is no way that
they would pitch in to work together to
make sure Society doesn't collapse uh uh
uh if under the weight of this violence
given that they are overwhelmingly the
ones perpetrating that violence they
hate higher education they say that's
liberal indoctrination uh they um say
that medicine is increasingly uh biased
left Wingers giving their social
opinions when it comes to vaccines and
all these other guidelines related to
the pandemic on all of these different
things they are willing to let the world
the country burn for their ideology it
doesn't matter science doesn't matter
empiricism doesn't matter reality
doesn't matter to them uh the other
aspect to this that is important to
consider
is that when you look at stochastic
terrorism meaning the vague calls to
violence
issued to their respective audiences you
just don't see that on the left now I
know you can find isolated examples of
some black lives matter or antifa
activist with no following other than
1500 people on Twitter saying down with
their heads or something like that but
what I'm talking about is
Tucker Carlson Alex Jones Steve Bannon
Trump himself at rallies the leaders of
their movement prominent people
saying we gotta knock him around knock
the hell out of them I'll pay for the
legal fees all of these different things
they are causing this to a great degree
and so the both sidesism has to stop and
by the way the more we learn about the
Paul Pelosi attack the more we know that
it was simply a right-wing nut targeting
Nancy Pelosi because he doesn't like her
political views let's talk about that
next we now have learned about
statements made by David de Pape the
attacker of Paul Pelosi Nancy Pelosi's
husband and he is straight up admitting
what this was this was a politically
motivated attack in which he wanted to
quote break Nancy Pelosi's kneecaps so
that she would then have to be wheeled
into Congress in a wheelchair which
would really show Democrats that there
are consequences to their actions
that's it folks it's just right-wing
violence that's all it is it's no he was
a gay prostitute who was home with Paul
Pelosi and they were engaged in a
lover's quarrel there's no evidence for
any of it and we're going to get to that
in a moment
it's just terrorism that's all it is
there's a good Rolling Stone article by
Miles Clee conspiracy theories about
Pelosi attacker debunked by Pelosi
attacker David depape told police he
planned to take the house Speaker
hostage and break her kneecaps if she
lied to him
that is the bottom line here this was a
sworn affidavit FBI special agent
Stephanie Miner who's a domestic
terrorism specialist described 42 year
old Berkeley Man David depape told
police he planned to take speaker Pelosi
hostage interrogate her and possibly
break her kneecaps she wasn't home at
the time of the invasion
depape broke through a rear glass door
of the residence with a hammer he later
used that hammer to beat Paul Pelosi he
brought zip ties tape rope and gloves
he was going to talk to her if she told
the truth he would release her if she
lied he would break her knee pack
kneecaps a debate described Pelosi as
quote leader of the pack of Lies told by
the Democratic Party
there uh is nothing nothing to the
right-wing conspiracy theories which we
will delve into a little bit more but
think about it he
is openly telling us why he did it
it's terrorism it's a form of domestic
terrorism it's violence against our
democratically elected uh uh uh
officials that's what it is and the Pape
said to it authorities he didn't flee
when Paul Pelosi was able to call 9-1-1
because quote much like the American
founding fathers with the British he was
fighting against tyranny without the
option of surrender Republicans are like
well he was a gay prostitute
the paper's like I'm not gay or a
prostitute I'm just a right-winger like
you guys
so maybe it was antifa some kind of
double agent a secret BLM member or
whatever but of course none of that
would be true and meanwhile Fox News
continues to give the conspiracy
theories the benefit of the doubt as the
conspiracy theories are increasingly
debunked Fox News has to play more and
more koi and just say it's not really
all adding up here's one such clip there
are a number of unanswered questions
regarding the case like who opened the
door for police and why did Paul Pelosi
allegedly describe de Pape at one point
in a conversation with authorities as a
friend and if he wasn't let in how did
he get up there and break in given the
amount of security in the area
of course we have most of those answers
already and we will talk in more detail
about some of those claims in a moment
but for now I want to talk about one of
the other claims that's regularly being
made about this attack
one of the completely baseless claims
that Republicans are making in response
to the Hammer attack on Nancy Pelosi's
husband Paul Pelosi is that this is all
the fault of Democrats defunding the
police and that prosecutors are too
lacks and that Democrat cities so-called
are extraordinarily dangerous this is
the line that they're coming up with the
truth is that this was a right winger
who didn't like Nancy Pelosi and wanted
to break her kneecaps so she would have
to be wheeled into the House of
Representative to send a message to
other Democrats you better be careful
your consequences have actions here is
Donald Trump's one-time acting uh
attorney general assistant Matt
Whittaker you guys remember this guy he
said we have to look at the bigger
picture how convenient forget about the
fact that David de Pape or depape was a
right winger anti-vaxx like Tim Poole uh
uh anti-semitic all this difference
forget about that
it's the bigger picture of democrat
crime in Democrat cities your reaction
to what took place uh to Paul Pelosi
yeah well obviously it's if as reported
it's a horrific you know uh invasion of
his home in in an assault on him uh and
it's you know political violence should
never and does not have a place in our
society we have to look at a bigger
picture Maria and that is is that San
Francisco is is crime riddled and a lot
of it is due to the lacks policies of
the local prosecutor and when you when
you take that context it's going to be
very interesting how this individual who
is charged with some serious crimes
whether he gets the same treatment of a
lot of the violent criminals right the
problem is they're going to treat him
more roughly than the other antifa BLM
whatever because this guy is maybe a
right-winger but maybe not understand
that this analysis is bogus uh Nancy
Pelosi and her husband weren't the
victims of a random home invasion
related to the broader crime situation
situation in San Francisco they were
targeted by a right winger for their
political views the lacks prosecution
whether you believe that's what is
taking place in San Francisco or not
um the the other one is the defunding of
police which hasn't happened this is a
specifically targeted crime and this is
a way of them trying to figure out how
do we blame attacks on Democrats on
Democrats themselves and understand the
incredible difference between these two
political groups you don't see
Democratic candidates with assault
rifles in their campaign ads you just
don't see it you don't see Democratic
campaign ads with Targets on Republicans
the way dating back to Sarah Palin and
much more recently we have seen
Republicans do and meanwhile I think
it's important to mention crime isn't
even actually up in San Francisco I I
know that they love to talk about this
just look up violent crime and property
crime and you will see that it it's just
it's just not up the the numbers are
very steady and even a little bit lower
than they were five years ago there has
been no defunding of the police in San
Francisco violent crime is just not up
and so even the premises on with which
some of these claims are based are
completely and totally untrue make sure
that if you watch our clips on YouTube
you're not just watching the Clips make
sure you hit that subscribe button it is
free every time you hit that subscribe
button Alex Jones grimaces Thank your
lucky stars every day you're not Dave
packman yeah
um there's nearly three million of you
that regularly watch our videos but are
not subscribed let's get to two million
folks hit that subscribe button we'll
take a quick break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
remember that the David packman show is
an audience supported program you can
sign up at joinpakman.com get the daily
bonus show just for members get the
daily podcast in audio or video form
with no commercials five or six hours
before everybody else gets it and get
the invites to the members only town
halls with me by simply signing up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code big
voting22. all right let's hit a couple
of other small stories related to the uh
politically violent right-wing attack on
Paul Pelosi Nancy Pelosi's husband I
continue to really like the tone and
tenor of California Democratic governor
Gavin newsom's analysis of a lot of
these uh realities of the modern right
wing he has been talking about this for
a long time he has been talking about
these are this is a violent movement in
many ways and January 6 proves that so
many different events prove that and he
was interviewed on kpix 5 and he is
making a stochastic terrorism argument
here I'm so glad that he is doing that
he is saying
look at what they put out on social
media
look at what they put out at rallies
look at the language that they use
of course people are going to start
committing violence on their behalf
tell me that's not alien betting all
this of course it is
to create a culture and a climate like
this
I mean it's it's look online look at the
sewage that is online that they amplify
on these networks and in social media to
dehumanize people like Nancy Pelosi and
other political leaders
Governor Newsom also said he's no
stranger to threats but says he believes
things are getting worse there's no
principle I know what
no witness three years to come in my
inbox
trust me you don't because I'm not
sharing it I don't even share with my
wife
I got four kids so I know a little bit
about this I mean it wasn't just a
recall against me it was surround sound
in every way shape or form uh
so of this Venom ah at a level I've I've
had it looked all
there's always folks in the extreme and
you roll your eyes it's just there's
something with the arena but this is
different this is something's different
here there's you know the mind is being
stretched people feel free to shove
again that's exactly right uh
you know we all talk about it folks in
in left-wing media like me all The Usual
Suspects if you watch any of you know
our other shows if you're in this
ecosystem we all get it to different
degrees uh certainly if one is Jewish
you get more of it we're seeing that for
sure uh but Gavin Newsom is completely
right what do you expect to happen
when you create for years year after
year after year
a culture an environment
in which this type of violence is
encouraged sometimes it's overtly
encouraged
uh but sometimes it is more implicitly
encouraged it's knock them around
it's I'll pay your legal fees it's
Targets on their backs in ads it's
someone's got to really show up and show
Nancy I mean just recently Trump at a
rally and others were specifically
targeting her so it's going to have an
impact and if it didn't
they wouldn't be saying it and then the
other really horrif horrifying thing
that we have to understand is
their violent rhetoric
encourages and causes the violence
when it then happens then they use it to
justify more Violence by saying listen
it's both sides are being very violent
antifa BLM and it then justifies hey
we're just being as violent as they are
even though it is of course completely
untrue statistically I gave you the data
earlier Fox News propagandist Tucker
Carlson
is now amplifying the conspiracy theory
that Elon Musk Amplified on Twitter
which he now owns yes the owner of
Twitter Elon Musk Amplified a conspiracy
theory uh it's a conspiracy theory that
goes something like this
um Paul Pelosi was in his underwear at
the time of the home invasion
which suggests that maybe it was
actually his gay lover who beat him with
a hammer and during the 9-1-1 call Paul
Pelosi allegedly also said this man is
my friend
um so therefore it's all an inside job
it was a lover's quarrel Etc it's been
totally debunked we'll talk about it in
a moment but now Tucker Carlson is
continuing to amplify this Elon Musk
deleted it from Twitter
but Tucker Carlson is single he was
pushed into doing that and there might
be something to that story I should just
come out with a piece that says I'm
recording Elon Musk in a tweet shares a
link from a site known to publish fake
news true really what did Elon Musk do
well he linked to an article about how
Paul Pelosi called the guy in his home a
friend
well that's what the 911 tape says you
can draw your own conclusions or not or
maybe you don't care which is also fine
how is that fake okay so let's go
through this piece by piece and you know
the the sad thing about this is
it's the right Wingers who need to have
this stuff debunked not mostly my
audience but I think it's important to
arm you with the knowledge about where
all of this stuff came from first of all
it was two in the morning lots of people
sleep in their underwear that's why Paul
Pelosi was was in his underwear okay
very very simple secondly there is no
evidence that Paul Pelosi actually said
this is my friend the number one so they
keep saying the transcript shows Paul
Pelosi said this is my friend what they
have is the claim that the dispatcher
said to police over the phone
he says it's his friend
but then moments later the dispatcher
clarified to police he doesn't know the
guy what is believed to have happened is
that much like that Viral 9-1-1 call
where a woman who is the victim of
domestic violence pretends to be
ordering pizza
in order to not anger the individual
that is being violent against her it is
believed that in order to keep things
calm and not trigger David to Pape into
more violence
Paul Pelosi may have said something like
no no no we're friendly he's my friend
but it was made abundantly clear on the
call and the 911 dispatcher understood
that this was a violent home invasion
and that police were needed that's it
there's there's nothing else to this but
Tucker wants to continue quote asking
questions but as long as this is a news
story with public policy implications
and unfortunately that's what it's
become it is fair to ask the obvious
questions as you would about any other
violent crime that occurs in America and
especially this one since so many facts
basic facts seem to be in dispute local
KTVU investigative reporter Evan
cernofsky for example initially reported
that the Papi was quote found in
underwear when police arrived today
sarnovsky made a specific point of
retracting that claim it seems it was
just Paul Pelosi who was in underwear
it's the early details were not
completely accurate was there underwear
there was and Paul Pelosi was the one
wearing it I'm now told by other sources
that the Papi was not dressed only in
his underwear well okay fair enough we'd
be satisfied with either explanation not
really our business
but you can't blame and this is the
point you can't blame people watching
all of us at home for thinking that
maybe there's something weird going on
here yeah and this is a classic of
conspiracy theorists read Stephen
novella's book about skeptical thinking
you find it's called anomaly hunting
okay you find a piece of information
that hasn't been released and you claim
it's part of the story that's part of
the story that piece of information was
wrong so later when it's clarified that
that's not a part of the story you claim
that the change or the inconsistency is
a red flag and there's probably more
there uh you um find some benign or
irrelevant detail that sounds strange
and you use that to amplify and say well
we can't trust any of the story because
this one detail doesn't make sense
whether or not it's true and again the
question you have to ask is not
what are the odds that Paul Pelosi is in
his underwear and says this is my friend
even though it was clearly a signal to
the 911 that's not that's the right
question when you when you when you ask
the question like that it's like wow
that doesn't make any sense instead if
you ask the question like this
what are the odds that in a situation as
traumatic and horrifying as a 2 A.M home
invasion by a violent lunatic with a
hammer uh the victim says or does
something that we from the outside can't
immediately explain or understand if
that's even what happened then you go oh
well that's super likely it's a crazy
situation
uh I mean I don't know what I would do
in such a situation then all of a sudden
these anomalies don't really make that
much of an impact on you and of course
they benefit from people not thinking
about things in those terms it was a
classic with the JFK assassination
conspiracy theories what are the odds
that on a sunny day
you have a guy with a black
umbrella
just 50 feet away from where Kennedy was
shot under suspicious circumstances that
doesn't make sense the guy with the
umbrella must be involved and of course
we know the guy was the umbrella was a
political protest If instead you say
what are the odds that along a parade
route with 80 000 people
someone does something weird on the same
day JFK's shy it's like oh yeah well
there's 80 000 someone's gonna do
something weird all of a sudden it's not
that compelling and that is exactly the
type of skeptical thinking we should
apply Kanye West continues his
anti-semitic anti-jewish tirade he now
is making the claim that a Jewish doctor
misdiagnosed him apparently on purpose
wanted him to take pills which could
have then been swapped out I guess with
poison Kanye is very much unwell but I'm
gonna tell you why this is so important
and he continues ranting about Jews
controlling entertainment and media and
medicine and on and on drove me to a
point of exhaustion which was
misdiagnosed by a I'm not gonna say what
race what people uh doctor
and what hospital and what media went to
we know I can't say that
it was a Jewish doctor that diagnosed me
of having a disorder that would have had
me on medication right now at a time
like this if I was on medication right
now
then one pill could have been swapped
out uh-oh right so it's not even that
the the real medication that the Jewish
doctor wanted him to take was the
problem it's that if he was on the
medication the pills could have been
swapped it would be Michael Jackson and
Prince all over again right but because
they might put propofol in there I
didn't take the misdiagnosis
and I didn't take the the uh medication
I'm able to speak to you guys
clear of thought and transparency so
this right here is a chart of
uh Universal Studios 20 20th Century Fox
ABC oh my God is he pulling up
anti-semitic memes on his phone he
sees news Columbia pictures uh Warner
Brothers ESPN sports Fox News Washington
Post let you go with my MTV Music
Television Nickelodeon USA Today Wall
Street Journal
now the thing is I skipped over maybe
about five of them because it was just
unclear on this list the red are the
executives that are Jewish okay so
listen
there's a lot of layers to this
it's very clear Kanye should be on
medication but I don't know what it was
that was being prescribed to him I I
can't say this enough
I know that he said or someone said at
one point oh Kanye has been diagnosed as
bipolar maybe it's schizoaffective
schizophrenia whatever
lots of those folks refused to take
medications okay
for so
he's having a mental health crisis
lots of people who have mental health
crises don't go to blaming the Jews so
we can't just say he's not really
anti-semitic he's just mentally ill okay
um it can it can be both things at the
same time he it's really common that
people find reasons not to take their
meds
for him it's because a Jewish doctor
wanted him to take the meds which could
then be swapped out with something that
could kill him
Kanye on his own saying this stuff isn't
really the issue the issue is the
alarming and extraordinarily large
number of people that agree with what
he's saying look at the comments on
YouTube under this video
and I am sure you will find people
agreeing with what Kanye says that's the
really scary part it's an important
thing to talk about he's not
anti-semitic because he's mentally ill
he seems mentally ill and he's
anti-semitic and the anti-Semitism is
coming out because he's uninhibited and
it's an important distinction to make
I'm going to be on Dr Rashad Ritchie's
show later today talking about it see
these clips on our Instagram at
davidpackman show and make sure folks if
you're watching this video right now on
YouTube
and you're not subscribed please hit
that subscribe button
if you value what we do at the David
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with the
president and CEO of Media Matters
Angelo carusone we're going to talk
about uh well many many different things
Angelo it's great to have you on I
appreciate it likewise thank you so to
start with
there is a feeling that Fox News in
particular and maybe some other
right-wing media are starting to set up
a little bit of like an eject button or
an escape hatch were Donald Trump not to
be the Republican nominee in 2024 Fox
News ran like a man on the street
segment where they had a bunch of people
saying oh no if it was up to me it would
be DeSantis who's the nominee they're
not really against Trump but it feels as
though they're setting up an escape
hatch is that your sense of what's going
on
yeah I think that's a really I like the
way that you put it because a lot of
people oftentimes put it like they've
turned on Trump right oh that's that's a
little extreme um but the escape hatch
is the right way to think about it which
is that you know one of the things that
has happened and is that you know in the
past Trump sort of captured Fox news's
audience and was able to really LeapFrog
Fox News and speak directly to them and
then the audience you know kind of
forced Fox to align that's how he
captured them he seized it he doesn't
have the same tools available to him
there's opposing candidates like
DeSantis that help create some of that
friction so what they're basically doing
is hedging um and I would just remind
everyone that this is a very similar
posture that Fox News was in and poor
place
um in 2015. you know in 2015 they had
the Fox News primary where you would
have candidates that would get a ton of
attention that would be the flavor of
the two weeks and they would shoot to
the top and there was people criticizing
Trump on air on network you know there
was factions within Fox that had
different people that they supported and
I think that started to emerge right now
I also think you know they're trying to
they're hedging because it's not clear
that Trump is going to be able to
replicate what he did in 20 in 2016 and
they kind of know it so escape hatch is
exactly the right way to put it to go
back to 2015 2016 there was that early
period where Fox was very much not on
the Trump train and as you say
ultimately they did acquiesce is there
anything about the backstory of the
relationship between Trump and the
murdochs that is relevant to how that
went or or was that not a factor in your
mind
it was not so much of a factor it was
really about Roger Ailes um the only
thing that was relevant at the time
about the murdochs is that Rupert
Murdoch has always wanted Fox to really
have a president like like not to just
have an alliance with the president you
know they were obviously aligned with
the Bush Administration
um but there was a they were two
different entities that sort of had some
Synergy and Alignment what Murdoch is
always fantasized about uh has been to
really create a president uh or you know
a world leader but really a president
and so what when ale started to put more
of the you know Foxy's juice behind
Trump as things started to seem to break
in his favor
um Murdoch really saw that as an
opportunity to create something and
that's where he sort of said okay I'm
all in now uh and then he cashed in on
those favors as soon as Trump got into
office right by doing some pretty
outrageous things trying to get him to
slow down the deals so that he could
muck with and maybe even buy CNN and you
know it really it that was the
determining Factor but it wasn't until
after it was pretty clear that Trump
could capture the nomination that
Murdoch said okay we can go all in now
before the FBI search at Mar-A-Lago
there was this stretch of time where
Trump was just gone from Fox News he was
doing and still is doing interviews
where oftentimes he's just literally
phoning it in channels that nobody's
heard of and you know it seemed as
though maybe this was a sign that his
star is fading after the search there
was the entire the Sean Hannity
interview which by the way was a total
total disaster didn't really do anything
good for him but put that aside for a
second was there something to that
absence from Fox News in your mind there
was
um now they still talked about him nine
to 10 15 times more than anybody else
yeah but there was something to it two
things actually one was that was the
beginning of the January 6 hearings and
there was all of this information coming
out testimony where you know there was
actually you know Fox News hosts were
part of it where they were actually
texting and talking so it complicated
things a little bit it and then the
second thing and this is really
important is that the defamation lawsuit
that from Dominion which is that voting
machine company that's suing Fox News
for a billion dollars
um they had been arguing for almost
seven eight months that the murdochs
would not be part of it
and just in the beginning of the summer
uh it was the the courts ruled that
actually the murdochs will be a part of
this litigation and what that meant is
that fox Executives in the murdochs were
trying to demonstrate that oh there's
some distance between us and Trump
um and there was a little bit of back
and forth over that summer as they
started to calibrate their legal
strategy so I think it was really those
two things coming together which is
let's keep him at arm's length because
every time he appears on our Network
he's either it's either going to create
a new round of stories about the our
hopes with January 6 or it's going to
complicate the back end stuff that we're
dealing with with this massive billion
dollar lawsuit so what I want to get off
Fox after one more question and get onto
some other right-wing media Outlets but
at this point do you have a sense of
who's more powerful within the
Republican base in terms of trump or Fox
News in the sense of if Trump says I'm
running and fox did decide we actually
want to prevent Trump from being the
nominee who who is the power right now
Tucker Tucker okay specifically yeah
it's just Tucker
um and so uh the rest of fox would have
to would break for Trump at this point
Fox would be able to capture uh Trump
would be able to hijack the fox audience
and we're seeing that play out a little
bit right now with the attacks on Pelosi
Posey's husband you know Fox initially
treated like a traditional crime story
and then after sort of the Trump part of
the ecosystem was weaving conspiracies
all of a sudden Fox News sort of broke
and went with the conspiracy Direction
so there's lots of indicators like that
um so if Fox was against Trump trump
would win that fight but if Tucker is
then Trump is in trouble because Tucker
really has replaced Limbaugh as sort of
like the what he used to describe as the
titular head of the Republican Party
Tucker has really filled that space so
Trump V Fox Trump trump V Tucker Tucker
what do you make of
um recently even Newsmax I so the way I
put some of these on a spectrum is
you've got Fox which is on the right and
then you've got Newsmax which is crazier
than Fox and then you've got oan which
is crazier than Newsmax that I sort of
have them like that and you can tell me
whether you agree or disagree Newsmax
recently is not even taking all of
Donald Trump's rallies they still take
most of them but not all of them does
that mean that even within the even
crazier Wing maybe Trump star is fading
a little bit and it's also you know it's
a little complicated too because they um
a lot some other entities went out there
and really cornered that market of the
rallies live so um you know Trump's own
lawyer hosts yeah right side
broadcasting right I mean when there so
I mean they have an inside track um Fox
News actually has an entire channel on
their Fox Nation app that they will give
away free trials for so they use the
Trump rallies to get more people to sign
up
um the entire section is devoted to just
Trump's rallies so they kind of others
got into the space to try to
commercialize it so I think there's a
financial like Corner in the market
Factor but I look at the metrics you
know they see that you know the rallies
don't have the same juice and star power
that they did in the past and for
Newsmax which has slightly thinner
margins
um it doesn't get them the same bang for
the buck and also every time he says
something about the election they have
to worry about their channels and
getting Zapped and so if for them it's
just it's just not worth it so you
talked a little bit about the Trump
versus someone else Primary in terms of
Tucker and the power dynamics there but
if we zoom out a little and even like
separate it maybe from from Fox News how
do you believe right-wing media more
generally will handle if it's Trump
DeSantis because I don't think DeSantis
can be written off as a rhino in the
same way that they do with like Mitt
Romney for example so what do you think
they're going to come up with for
covering such a primary it's going to be
really hard there's two complicating
facts there's two big considerations one
is that
um DeSantis has a pretty potent piece of
like Kryptonite uh that he started to
deploy which is vaccines and it started
over the summer and he started to
basically you know he's been apologizing
for saying that he he was misled he
should have never promoted the vaccines
it's it's probably the only wedge where
he can really successfully outflank
Trump
um on to the right and and have
credibility with the right-wing media
and that's what it's about it's about
sort of hijacking the right we're
outflanking Trump when it comes to some
of these right-wing personalities to say
look at the Santos you know he's willing
to accept the fact that he should have
never and he's been anti-vaxx and he's
anti-state control and we're free for
you know Liberty and you know he did it
a little bit over the summer and it
worked
um it changed the way right-wing media
talked about them that's when Alex Jones
started to really hit Donald Trump was
on the vaccine stuff and then you could
look at a bunch of these right-wing
media hosts that were saying oh Trump's
going to have to Grapple with this at
some point why won't he just say he was
lied to why won't he apologize about
this he's so stubborn and so Santa
started to you know basically deploy it
as a trial balloon did it for about six
weeks and he walked it back so I think
one is how heavily he leans into that
and how Trump navigates that as a
weakness because Trump's base is not
with Trump on this and that is this
weird tension where he's out of step
with them
um and so that's one and I think that
will affect the way the right media
lines up because it will give them cover
to then criticize Trump in a way that
doesn't get them blow back from their
own audiences
um is to get him on that terrain so
that's that's one part and then the
other part is is actually a knock
against DeSantis is that DeSantis is no
fun
so the truth is nobody really likes him
that's what everyone's hedging on and
I'm not trying to be mean or glib about
it's the truth he really is no fun even
as close as allies acknowledge that he's
genuinely no fun he's aloof he's not
charismatic he's and if you're in the
media you need to think about the
product
um and what's the sustaining and staying
power and that's the challenge with
DeSantis is that I think from the media
perspective they're all aware of the
fact that DeSantis doesn't have the same
you sort of like regenerative power in
terms of media consumption in the way
that that Trump does so it's this weird
thing but I do think the vaccine piece
is going to really be challenging and
Trump is going to take a lot of flack
for that from the right-wing media and
if they want to jump that's going to be
their launch pad last thing I want to
ask you about what is the timing of the
2024 Primary getting going because some
part of me thinks it gets going on
November 9th quite frankly
yeah I think you're right um I have
always been pointing to the fact that um
there's no way that Trump would announce
a candidacy until his airplane was ready
and uh it was supposed to be ready back
in July but of course because of all the
supply chain issues pieces of it weren't
complete and the timeline got radically
disrupted it is now officially finished
there's no way that he would run for
president without his plane it's too
it's too much of an important part of
the staging right um and so it's just it
was an obvious to me it just felt very
obvious that he couldn't be a candidate
without his plane it doesn't work
um and and so that's to me uh if this
plane wasn't ready I would say we have
to wait uh but because his plane is now
ready I I agree with you I think it's
going to start almost immediately after
November 9th and that ties into what's
happening now because a lot of what's
happening on the ground the
infrastructure at the state level a lot
of the organizations the the cluster of
groups that are going to get power or
potentially get power if the election
goes in their favor this is all part of
the Trump ecosystem that has been
building this groundwork so it's gonna
almost be at the Apex and a lot of
momentum for him to make a quick jump I
and he's also seen to the extent that
they're going to challenge any elections
he's really the face of that strategy
and approach so I think you're right
it's going to start very very very early
and it sounds like from the language
you're using you have no doubt
whatsoever that Trump is running
yeah I think he's going to run for sure
um uh I do I don't think there's any
reason to stop him from running and uh
he is fueled in large part by Spite and
revenge and every measurable indicator
still shows that he could succeed in the
primary he his assessment of DeSantis is
that he is too miserable of a person to
successfully High to replace him as the
head of the party
um and uh DeSantis I think is gonna I
think he's a little hesitant to get too
bloodied up by Trump
um because it can be a messy battle so
there is a little bit of a delicate
Balancing Act there
um but yeah I do I think for a lot of
reasons there's no there's no doubt that
he will in my mind that he will run
unless there's some major intervening
circumstance this is really the last
thing and then I'll let you go
um it it seems very clear that there's a
lot of people in right-wing media right
now and even some of the candidates
starting to prepare for if we lose it
was rigged but we also know that that
caused significant legal problems for a
lot of media when they did it with 2020.
what do you expect on November 9th 10th
11th as far as that story goes
yeah I think the one thing that I would
just point out I'm glad you asked this
is that um because it demonstrated to be
a challenge they've adapted and well the
way that they adapted was by building an
infrastructure of these groups and
entities that they'll be able to cite
and reference and they're disposable so
you could say so they can say this group
makes this claim and they filed this
lawsuit exactly yeah exactly and so they
really and there's a lot of centers
about 14 of them in operation right now
they're promoting all these apps that
help collect this information most of
them are disposable they're not
infrastructure they're not designed to
have staying power they're shells and
that was a way that and they've done
little ones at the major States there's
one in Pennsylvania there's one in
Arizona they're all tied into right-wing
media they get a lot of attention a lot
of press a lot of Engagement a lot of
audience traction they've been bumping
pumping them up now for about about 10
months and so that's the workaround is
that they found a way to essentially
create a shield so that the media
operations can engage in the same kinds
of attacks but now they have this layer
of cover they'll never get sued for
citing a third-party organization a
third-party organization can get sued
um but they won't that was Fox's problem
you know in in 20 in 2016 2020 is that
they were just saying these things that
they were getting texted you know they
were the source and now they've really
found a way to to create that and I
think that is the one thing that I don't
think people broadly have a full handle
on is that they've built the
infrastructure to actually create do
what they did in 2020 but at scale in a
much more professional way uh and in a
much more uh scale and much more volume
yeah slick and scary at the same time I
guess I would say but we've been
speaking with the president and CEO of
Media Matters Angelo Carrison always uh
great to talk to you and appreciate your
insights thanks for having me
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
Donald Trump did a couple of whacked out
interviews the first of which is on a
platform called Americano Media or
Americano in other words it's a right
wing it it's new they get like 2 000
views of video it's quite wild it's a
right wing
American Spanish language Outlet or
Channel I don't even really know what to
call it and this is I guess where Donald
Trump is now being interviewed these
clips are sometimes only getting a
couple thousand views this particular
one has seven thousand views and this is
where Trump's now being interviewed the
topic of Elon musk's takeover of Twitter
came up this has been a big point of
contention is Trump going back to
Twitter if he is unbanned which would of
course completely torpedo truth social
Trump says he's not with truth social
yeah and the opportunity to have freedom
of speech which is very important for
democracy right and now knowing that
Elon Musk has take control of Twitter do
you see that there is an opportunity for
a broader freedom of speech in this
country that can help you know ease up
all these ideas and all this censorship
that the you know many people have been
submitted to in the past few years it's
very good that Elon took over Twitter it
was run by Maniacs radical left lunatics
and they were
I mean it was all Bots and fake accounts
a lot of it
and it was a disaster okay and I had
hundreds of millions of people between
Facebook and Twitter more than just
about anybody else
and all of a sudden one day you don't
have your voice anymore
and I created after telling all sorts of
corrosive lies and inciting violence
right that's the little detail he lives
suddenly my voice was gone after I did a
b c d e all in violation of Twitter's
terms of service truth social and it's
been amazingly successful it's almost
bankrupt last week as you saw it was
above Tic Tac it was above Twitter it
was about it it's been an amazing
success so you know I like it I'm saying
on Truth social I like it better yep so
Trump is staying on truth truth Central
is where he will be staying Donald Trump
in a moment that makes no sense
whatsoever says he thinks the search
warrant at Mar-A-Lago will make Hispanic
people vote for him but Trump thinks
everything will make Hispanic people
vote for him we don't straighten this
country you're going to end up you are
literally going to end up with a
Venezuela on steroids meaning a bigger
version of Venezuela and that's where
our country is going if you look at
what's happening yeah the raid on
Mar-A-Lago
people were disgusted by it
but
Hispanics saw that as what happened and
many of them come from countries that we
know very well oh God is he saying that
when a search warrant was served at
Mar-A-Lago it was like the abuses of
power corruption and dictatorial
Insanity in Venezuela is that is that
the argument he's making
they said that's what happened
from where they came
oh God that is just Rich a completely
legal uh eyes dotted and T's crossed uh
search warrant being executed when there
is so much probable cause that's like
that's like what Chavez did that is just
wild
um and Trump actually talks more about
Venezuela you take a look at Venezuela
go back 20 years Venezuela very
prosperous rich country it was the
richest country in Latin America it was
you know everything was pretty good
and now you look they don't have water
they don't have food they don't have
anything they have a dictatorship
and on the campaign I was saying that if
we don't straighten this country out
you're going to end up you are literally
going to end up with a Venezuela on
steroids there you go and I have to tell
you Trump finally getting something
right it is true I believe in the year
2001 or 2000 Venezuela was
um the most prosperous country in South
America that he he finally stumbled
across a historical fact that is true uh
Trump is now also doing the communism
stuff without understanding a word of it
well the American dream will be gone the
American dream with Communism is never
going to be here
and you know once it goes there it's
very hard to bring it back yes well of
course there are no Communists in
positions of power in the United States
there just aren't any and then Trump
confirming he doesn't even know what
these terms even mean I think that the
election coming up on the eighth and the
following election very importantly
which is now think of it it's two years
away it's very quick quick how it
happens time flies
uh I think if we don't do well in those
two elections our country is gone
and I really believe we pass socialism
you know we've just stepped over
socialism we're into communism that's
what's happening if you look at the
justice department the FBI you look at
the kind of things that are going on
with
law enforcement and what they're doing
we have forgotten them so he's gone from
supporting law enforcement to now that
the FBI served a search warrant at
Mar-A-Lago
law enforcement is evidence of Communism
about socialism we're into communism
we're into Soviet Union stuff
it's very bad and it's very dangerous
for this country and people are angry
about it yeah Trump continuing to have
no idea what socialism is what communism
is the difference between the two or
whether there's any of it here in the
United States as orange and sweaty as
ever and even the friendliest interviews
he just cannot make any sense
let's go down to another interview
that is absolutely chilling Donald Trump
says that the reporters who broke the
story on Roe v Wade getting overturned
should be jailed and forced to give up
the name of the Supreme Court leaker
this was an interview with the
right-wing Sebastian Gorka hard to
imagine a friendlier interviewer to
Trump and it is just absolutely bone
chilling Catherine Engelbrecht the uh
the heroine and the hero of 2000 mules
her partner Greg Phillips were arrested
for refusing to give up their souls how
come they don't do this with the leaker
the leaker of the Supreme Court because
if you went and got to that reporter
that's a terrible thing that happened it
puts out justices at tremendous risk and
that continues so they can't find the
liquor it's very easy to find the liquor
if you did the same thing to the
reporter as you did to Catherine
Engelbrecht he's a great woman uh you
say we want to know who the leaker was
because the leaker gave the story to
this reporter so so why aren't you doing
that yeah so as you can see a very
healthy respect here for freedom of the
press and independent journalists now
they're lying to you by the way you know
they talk about oh but other peoples
have been other people have been jailed
when they didn't give up their Source
the true the vote leaders were jailed
after being found in contempt for not
complying with the legal judicial order
to identify a believed criminal behind a
data breach at the heart of these
conspiracy claims regarding China and
our elections it was not about
journalistic sources it was about
identifying a criminal a believed
criminal completely different situation
altogether just does it doesn't make any
sense Phillips and Engelbrecht declined
to name a particular individual because
of the conspiratorial belief that the
guy is an FBI informant which is just
crazy they're just Bonkers people they
were escorted out of a courtroom by U.S
Marshals it has nothing to do with what
Trump and Gorka are talking about here
it is a chilling attack on journalism
and Independence of media and then Trump
talks about General Mark milley and the
infamous walk to the church uh and it's
it's just insane well Millie was weak
when I heard what he did because what he
walk in with the president he should
have said this is a great honor the
president held up a Bible and many
people why should why should a general
praise
of religiously tainted Stunt by a
president why is that what Millie has to
do people are very proud to have been in
that group but yeah
was when he when I heard him give an
apology I said he's gone and he was gone
he was weak he was in a and he's woke
and now I understand he I watch him
talking about white privilege and how
terrible everything is and you know it's
just it's not even believable that a guy
uh could have gotten to that place yeah
listen anybody with a good head on their
shoulders would have seen that Bible
walk stunt where they cleared the
protesters and walked to the church with
Trump holding up a Bible any reasonable
person would have seen that and said
that looks like a fascist I'm not saying
he is one or that the country has gone
fascist but that looks like the imagery
of a fascist of totalitarianism it looks
horrifying and we should all be against
it but Trump is mad that Millie didn't
suck up to him and go wow sir this was
such an amazing thing scary scary stuff
one last Quick story here on Trump
Donald Trump is now begging the Supreme
Court please hide my taxes please please
hide my taxes for someone who has
nothing to hide I have never seen anyone
go through this amount of trouble to
prevent their taxes from going public
CNN reporting former president Donald
Trump has asked the Supreme Court to put
on hold the release of his tax returns
by the IRS to a democratic lead house
committee
Trump filed the emergency request Monday
with the high court after a federal
appeals court as I told you cleared the
way last week for Trump's returns to be
disclosed to the house Ways and Means
Committee the case is the most direct
way for the house to get Trump's federal
tax returns after trying other avenues
for years the Trump team wants the
Supreme Court to put the release of the
tax returns on pause while the justices
consider whether to take the case up
uh to review the lower court decision
this is this is the last Salva this
really is the last Salvo as far as every
legal analyst I've spoken to has told me
an appeals court has already ruled
asking the Supreme Court to look at it
is the 100 last chance if they don't
take it up then the Democratic house
committee gets Trump's tax returns do
they probably leak from there I don't
know maybe they do I would never
encourage anybody to do anything illegal
and if they were to leak I would
absolutely look at them that's where I
will put it so this is Trump desperately
begging the Supreme Court to save him
what do we believe at this point would
be in those documents well I I don't
think it has changed number one the
documents might reveal Donald Trump is
not as wealthy as he claims to be at
this point we know that so I don't think
that that would be a big surprise
number two they might reveal income
sources that are inconvenient or
problematic for Trump What specifically
they would be is the stuff of
speculation
and number three they might further
confirm another thing we already know
which is Trump uses very different
values for assets depending on what his
objective is
all things we suspect but it would be
confirmation we have a great bonus show
for you today we will talk a little bit
more about Kanye West who is now
suspended from Instagram for
anti-submitic comments the high school
football coach who led the prayers on
the field
is getting his job back and we do it
every year we will again rant and Rave
about daylight saving time it is not a
settled issue it is very much not a
settled issue all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad the money is being
made and everybody here is good you can
sign up at joinpakman.com I will see you
then